the last six months were the most
challenging the European Union has ever
faced
what did Parliament do to tackle the
multiple crises and invest in the future
MEP is kicked off the year by welcoming
the Commission's European Green Deal and
pushing for its cornerstone the climate
law to reduce co2 emissions by 55
percent by 2030 from high hopes to big
changes mep s from 27 member states bid
goodbye to their british colleagues by
the end of January Parliament had
approved the UK's withdrawal agreement
setting brexit into motion while one
partnership came undone
another was forged the EU Vietnam trade
deal accepted by a majority of MEP s
removes nearly all tariffs while
protecting European standards and values
by far the biggest challenge of 2020 was
the Kovach 19 pandemic to fight back
Parliament started by approving
investment in solutions research into
treatments and vaccines were prioritized
through horizon 2020 they are roughly 20
teams around the world working on that
and we are going to see a variety of
answers to that and then we have to see
what is the most plausible one to
mass-produce the EU began investing
hundreds of billions of euros in support
programs for small businesses health
care the most vulnerable and
humanitarian aid to make sure no one is
left behind while battling one of the
biggest health crises to date MEP s kept
democracy alive by working from home and
voting remotely for the first time ever
as Europe was coming together to fight
the virus the EU marked 70 years since
the Schumann Declaration that led to the
foundation of the EU this year Europe
Day highlighted the need for unity and
solidarity in the EU while kovat 19 was
spreading across the continent
so was fake news in June Parliament's
established a special committee on
foreign interference in
democratic processes in the EU including
disinformation border closures
introduced to slow the spread of kovat
19 were a setback for freedom of
movement if there is one asset for which
the European citizens to appraise the
European experience is precisely because
pre movement it is of the essence
without Schengen there will be no
recovery 2020 is the year of long term
budget negotiations 750 billion euros
were put forward as a coronavirus
borrowing plan for the recovery
Parliament's warned that this should not
reduce the ambitions or the scope of the
next 7 year budget the road to recovery
is only beginning but Parliament is
ready to be ambitious and invest in the
future
[Music]
you